alright let's take some phone calls
today the number is 6 1 7 8 30 40 750 we
will start with name and where you're
calling from and then we'll see what
people are thinking of today who's on
first with me yeah this is from a curb
or from Arlington Virginia Frank what's
going on but nothing I just uh one thing
is that I've been around for a lot of
elections and after a lot of most of the
elections people were disappointed and
this time I see a lot of people who are
terrified which is very very different
yeah that's interesting I mean I think
that every there's been critiques made
of Democrats that they're unhinged over
the results but I think you're getting
at something interesting which is there
it's not just that Democrats are angry
because of political disagreements there
is genuine fear about what is going to
come and I think the cabinet pics we've
seen everybody from jeff Sessions the
guy who like the KKK till he found out
that they smoked weed to Tom Price who
has a you know negative 10 rating from
normal and is a hundred rating from
national right to life and wants to
dismantle Obamacare I think it's
legitimate to be afraid well the only
thing I thought over the discussion with
a friend of mine was uh I said is Willie
Morris barman I heard one of his
lectures on YouTube a couple nights ago
he said that you know though all the
systems in society corrupt and the only
thing I thought of such as a remedy for
that is for not being for us ourselves
well you know what system is working
really really well in government you get
into government and then you can use
that power to personally enrich yourself
through businesses and lobbying and
consulting and all of that stuff that
system has been worked out and it's
working perfectly for the plutocrats reg
so that's one system where corrupt or
not it's just working uh exactly as
designed and that's why it's going to be
so difficult to change it a Frank always
great to hear from one thank you so much
for the call I got one one other thing
to tell you their core badal had a great
line one time he said an honest
politician will cite broke yeah and you
know what if you see uh you I think that
there's something to that without
getting into examples I think you're
right that there is a lot
to that all right Frank thank you so
much for the call always great to hear
from Frank